welcome to this video FM h sk mark to
hardy kinda yeah played a number of
times with a bad score let's see can I
do any better this time last game i
blundered terribly in the in the
Auerbach this time I'm going to play it
like as safe as possible let's just play
a super boring game I didn't want super
boring okay I had this recently some guy
just playing knight c6 and we transpose
into the black very ation when I do that
ok maybe you go here on D Phi they have
I can take and play a four right played
a very quickly as usual the most
committal move this has to be played
instantly but okay it's it's probably
not that bad huh so d 5 or am evil event
of course let's let's start with that
yeah 11 possible issue is this one right
36 and d5 hangs sorry
so we'll just jump to the six right come
on let's let's play a move quickly for
once probably blundering you play a move
quickly Adam just throwing the whole
game away but it doesn't look very
lightly let's see however is there
Bishop Bishop is three years also just
trying to play but should be six and 95
stare a tactic or something it looks a
bit vulnerable only three and don't see
one I always have a night xe8 I mean
night takes d5 those karamu slam
probably not working okay so i can take
here take on d5 then Bishop c4 for f7
now come on let's let's do that just for
once play super simple stuff
okay so if i take now now let's just
start with bishops info
voice have rook be one and send things
and f7 of course I mean at the moment f7
is just tough too tough to project k
would be one or is there better move I
don't know just try to be a bit quicker
than usual I can take f7 it's not not
bad well just do that come on night be
seven or should always keep an advantage
so just take it I mean King h8 or
something and it's really not not a move
to be very enthusiastic about and
otherwise I just returned to the six and
keep the keep the pressure on
I don't really see how he should defend
this I mean getting this to d6 back it's
a pawn down ineffective tough to defend
okay I 493 edits it's not a bad idea 96
sighs just a trade
a good news that was a good move
cannot play Bishop b3 and 93 is a very
serious threat hmm okay
maybe bishop age six or something mmm I
don't know it was a very good movie
night at five I mean
Bishop h6 is possible try to undermine
their this was also yeah
G for 93 years not great maybe here I
never wanted to go there to be honest
but how came maybe protect first
can you take on no ABS a chick no I
don't have the check
Bishop d3 can really just take on a form
what a shame time morning everyone I
don't know I cannot calculate this
nonsense Bishop f4 Luke f1 yeah look B
aid and those kind of moves are the
problem with everything hangs okay so
here i mean i can't play can I go look
before and it's got look b8
Jim I don't don't really see how to I
can do this it looks kind of strange
now you can take a phone I guess
ah well which wait not one they don't
want to step into the first fork that
that pops up check probably I step into
the second one I still have the better
minor piece of course at least
theoretically speaking of course and
blitz the forks our production ematic
check ready for the forks the damn Forks
check check a black for fence on FB 55 I
think I think I'm winning actually I
have a meeting I should I mating meeting
him yeah of course it was a was a time
time time thing yeah but Wow yeah I mean
how did he defend all the time it was it
was kind of I mean this is this is
really nice for Wyatt but it wasn't it
wasn't easy to win Joe somehow the
coordination wasn't great but what what
so today did I lower that lemme check
rookie oneness the combo maybe just
preventing 93 a g5 I didn't really think
about g5 then much 96's them yeah maybe
yeah this is possible i saw that but i
thought that this is just too little but
if you look at what i had in the game
this looks really okay i'm the the
bishop here is still having some
pressure it's George
and here I don't know at all here 95 is
good now it was very tricky all those
loose pieces and I here could have won
with this chatting because of the mate
wyd wins funny that no chance no chance
to see that again Rock g one was better
I had no time and here I was very close
to stepping into the fourth yeah I mean
here we should end in a draw but check
of course with the time many things are
possible i TL this is this a sermon
active might appease why does sunshine
is better no but very difficult with
with the time it sir it's very very much
dependent on luck check item at the end
I mean here white is Winnie this is made
even check check yeah so some sort of
made with the Queen okay well thanks for
watching